vous êtes vous déjà senti abandonné
révolte et enragé en public
nos politiciens font de belles promesses
mais toujours dans leur seul et unique
intérêt une vague de violence sans
précédent frappe le quartier défavorisé
depuis que je suis flic je constate la
puissance de la justice incapables de
nous protéger des fléaux qui rongent
notre société
la police enquête sur la mort d'une
infusion la plupart se contente
d'espérer des jours meilleurs est moins
grand sourire
1 2 3 et il s'accroche à ce qu'il
faisait à l'émotion fait et nous le
faisons supplie
moi je n'ai plus rien je jure de
nettoyer cette ville peu importe le prix
c'est sa mort ont tué trop d'innocents
[Musique]
qu est-ce qu ainsi pas réussi à depuis
cinq personnes sont laissé aucun espace
à maryse promotion fusils à longue
portée ou et suisse chaque type de
combat
je suis partout
je ne suis nulle part
vous ne m'avez jamais vu
mais au collet c'est un an
lévis les plus hautes sphères de la
politique du pays pour la paix désormais